[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to this first ever episode of
cacao now
this new show will give you updates and
announcements on the titles that we
surface in europe and north america
whether you're fighting for victory in
alien
conquering the lands in archeage
going on classic adventures in guardian
tales plugging yourself into the royal
road in moonlight sculptor or trying to
be the last one standing in eternal
return we all thank you sincerely for
playing our games and as you're tuning
in to this show
before we jump in today i'd like to
settle the dust on what you can expect
from us today
well i'd love to have bombastic trailers
during this show and we will in future
episodes today we're taking you behind
the scenes on a few of our titles while
we make announcements before we're
normally ready to do them
that's exactly the purpose of this show
redefine how we interact with you our
communities and give you some early
looks into what our development partners
have in store for your favorite games
so without further ado let's jump right
in to the show
[Music]
[Music]
hi i'm siam yukimura and today i'm going
to reveal a lot of content and
improvements finally coming to alien in
the near future exciting isn't it let's
start
[Music]
in this brand new raid 30 players will
face irukas a dragon that has
obliterated his opponents at dragon's
arena and crowned the king of battles
irukas boasted gigantic sides and pitch
black flames eagerly waiting to displace
power against those foolish enough to
think that extended chance against him
[Music]
this raid heavily focuses on teamwork
and its challengers will be expected to
evade attack patterns as a team
the temple of desire is a new clan based
hunting ground in this area you will be
able to attack any player from enemy
clans regardless of your faction
clans will compete to occupy high
efficiency hunting grounds and maximize
their profits
there are several floors in the temple
of desire to proceed to the next level
you will need to add an entry ticket in
your possession
the secret sea is a new underwater
hunting ground and to reach it you will
obviously need a proper means of
transportation
with the help of submarines you will be
able to travel the sea visit islands go
underwater and hunter monsters living at
the bottom of the ocean
a new type of battle on a never before
seen scale will be added
powerful mega manamax will be present
that will require protection from their
owner clan's members and their strategic
use will be vital towards victory
in the meantime a new castle siege
system is in development that further
utilize these jargon modes
clans involved will either be defending
or sieging the castle and fight to
occupy it
speaking of juggernauts here are some
concept of boss monsters that the game
developers have been working on
this will make an appearance both in the
aforementioned and future content
wielding a sword and shield
paladins are valuable resources that
utilize physical attacks and the light
attribute
paladins make use of ours allowing them
to swap between offensive and supportive
stances and selectively maximizing the
effect of certain skills
their offensive aura grants them ranged
attacks as effective as magic classes
giving them the opportunity to deal
massive instant damage
their supportive aura grants powerful
healing and defensive capabilities that
will prove to be vital for their teams
with its dual role setup the new
palleting class will satisfy those
looking for more tactical gameplay
[Music]
the soul bringer is a melee class with a
fast tempo that wields a sword and
manipulates souls
soulbringers rely on combo attacks that
inflict fatal wounds to their opponents
by exposing their weakness of their
souls
they are incredibly fast hunters all
thanks to their swiftness and freedom of
movement control
[Music]
the now removed real war has attracted a
lot of players interest and its removal
has certainly left a hole in the alien
experience
the developers have been hard at work to
resolve previously identified issues and
provide everyone with an exciting new
mass scale pvp experience
first more attention will be given to
the balance of the war the aim is to
prevent unfair situation to the
population differences and ensure an
equal playing field
furthermore the system will be improved
to avoid situations where players feel
like they need repeatedly participate in
the real world to be able to obtain
their desired rewards
[Music]
the real vs real nature of alien
sometimes creates situations where a
player finds themselves in an unsolved
conflict during the progression
in order to reduce the pressure that
stems from such incidents the game
developers plan on creating a pvp and a
pve channel each suitable for different
playstyles
improvements to the party logic are also
planned where players can optionally
form parties not only in battlefields
but also dungeons and assault teams
[Music]
and now let's talk about quality of life
improvements
updates are being planned that aim at
reducing items that occupy space in your
inventory and storage unnecessarily
the first step in this process is to
minimize the amount of different types
of upgrade stones per level but also
items such as runestones upgrade stones
and blessing crystals
the character progression paths in their
current state failed to fully explain
the complexity of upgrading or improving
items and in turn affect the clarity of
skill attributes rune attributes man
awakening equipment enhancement
runestone slot and more
a restructure is planned to make
progression more clear and intuitive
equipment progression is difficult and
results often do not reflect the effort
put into it
an example of this is breakthrough
equipment
the breakthrough system is being revised
in a way that it no longer breaks upon
failure however with this change the
characteristics of breakthrough
equipment will also be altered
they will become untradable
unenhanceable
and understandable
requiring players to enhance new
equipment in case they want to change
builds
furthermore the amount of equippable
breakthrough items will be increased
when certain conditions are met
this way players that haven't been lucky
with legendary great equipment will have
a chance to increase their item level
with breakthrough gear
another not worthy change is the
conversion of all runestone slots into
balanced lots
this will give players the freedom to
customize their builds without worrying
about converting the slots of each new
gear they obtain
finally a fail stack system is planned
to lessen the frustration of enhancement
failures
while we are unable to disclose all the
details yet our goal is to create a
virtual cycle of progression while
retaining the value of existing
equipment
[Music]
by a popular demand i'm very excited to
announce that an update is planned that
supports gamepads with full game
coverage
i hope you are excited for all the new
content we are bringing to the game soon
while we also update existing systems
based on your feedback make sure to
follow our social media channels for the
latest updates on alien including the
full roadmap video for the game that
will be dropping somewhere next week
thanks for watching and enjoy the rest
of the show
it's so incredibly nice to be able to
announce the new paladin class a new
30-man raid controller support and so
much more coming to alien in the near
future
we sincerely can't wait for you to get
your hands on it
within the next week we'll announce more
information on the future of elian
make sure to follow our social media
channels to not miss out on any new
information regarding alien
now
on to archeage
in december 2021 we started on this
adventure at cacao games and we couldn't
be more excited for what developer xl
games is bringing for the future of this
franchise
i hope you all got the hint from the
announcement trailer back then right
and join you in new adventures yet to
come
while we're not close to being ready to
share anything about that we want to
sincerely thank you all for your support
during some of the difficulties we faced
while transferring this game from the
previous publisher to our service
[Music]
for some new announcements on archeage
i'd like to introduce cm cosmo who for
some reason always says she's not cosmo
[Music]
[Applause]
good morning afternoon and evening
inheritors i am definitely not cosmo and
i wanted to talk to you today about some
of the exciting updates that are going
to be coming to arcade and arcade and
jade
[Music]
first off let's talk arc pass there's
been a ton of feedback about the past
that's unchanged right now and the
general consensus was that it was pretty
boring and while the mother storm income
was pretty nice it just didn't have the
cool rewards that people felt that
legacy did have so we took that and went
back and forth to make something that
really felt unique with cool rewards
while not being overpowered and thus let
me tell you about the first new style of
arc pass coming in late march for
unchained
so the pass is planned to make its
appearance around the end of march
bringing with it a whole new set of
rewards which you can see in my
inventory
[Applause]
[Music]
we really wanted to ramp up a lot of the
rewards and make it more diverse when it
comes to what you receive
the main prize for completing this pass
is the steel lightning mount
the steel lightning is a pretty cool
mount with the usual set of speed boost
and stun skills but what really makes it
great is its stealth skill it's perfect
for sneaking up on reds or greens trying
to hand in on fruit edge
i'm super excited for the new arc pass
but i would imagine that a whole lot of
you guys are saying but we wanted the
typhoon drake and the vine giant and
trust me i get it
really but worry not we've managed to
get the typhoon drake inside the arc
pass rewards that we plan to bring to
unchained in april but more on that a
little bit later
[Music]
another thing that we wanted to address
since it's also a concern of ours is
that the mana storm crystal output of
this arc pass looks a wee bit less than
previous iterations and that is
something we agree with for this pass it
will stay the way that it is but we do
have improvements planned for the future
passes so
keep your eyes open for more info on
those
so everyone's been looking forward to
march for a while now and i wanted to
shed some light on the updates that
we've got planned we have the new tier
three aeronautical looks coming that'll
be a really big boost for a lot of
people those are going to be named the
brilliant aeronaut wind song twin tail
bastion arrow flash and hatchet blade
cloaks
to awaken your current clocks you'll
have to craft a radiant aeronaut clock
awakening scroll
it's time to start stacking honor and
push an egg is some whale song since we
know that trying to get those awakens
going to be a grand and a half
i hope you're ready to get back into
awakening because awakening is super fun
we're also expecting an update to the mr
song summit dungeon where you can find
out more about how it was formed in the
early days of ethereum as well as being
able to queue with members of new year
hiranya and pirate
so some of you have probably been
wondering where i've been this entire
time and i'd like to show off the great
prairie of the west
now the prairie is where the furin lived
before the great migration to hiranya
although it wasn't called haronia at the
time
this zone is planned to come in the
summer update i'm really looking forward
to it i hope you guys are as well
there'll be more information on this as
it comes because i'm i'm really hyped to
get into the nitty gritty of the lore
and what happened here at plains eye
we're gonna find out more soon
[Music]
that's all from me about arcade and
archeage and chain but please feel free
to reach out if you want to talk about
the lore or anything about the game but
for now enjoy the rest of cacao now
our gauge
again
thanks for supporting the arcade journey
we just started at cacao games
we're in this together and we tell you
your feedback
now it's time to give you a few updates
on our mobile titles
[Music]
hello everyone this is cm jackie and i'm
excited to bring you some news about our
mobile titles
[Music]
over the course of the coming days we
are launching three events to celebrate
300 days of moonlight sculptor
we have attendance rewards hot time bars
and a special gift planned for you
make sure to log in daily to not miss
out
rewards include enchant protectants body
eggs and a special costume item
we have also taken a look at class
rankings and got into contact with our
top players of each region we hope this
will be a great step into improving
moonlight sculptor and communicating
more closely with our players
jungle
[Music]
let's take a look at guardian tales
guardians are you ready for world 14
prepare for the demon shire where a
bizarre adventure awaits
while we cannot share much more yet have
an exclusive look at some of the concept
art for the upcoming world
[Music]
i hope you're as excited as i am
we are preparing special rewards to
celebrate its release and we will reveal
more information very soon
as always make sure to keep an eye on
our social media channels and with that
back to cm kareem
[Music]
[Applause]
whether you play moonlight sculpture
guardian tales or any of our other
titles on your phones tablets or on
emulators we see you we all sincerely
thank you for playing
please follow our social media channels
and join the official discords to get
the news when it's hot
[Music]
you thought that was it for today
nah
what would a show like this be without a
banger at the end
while we do not have a trailer or any
gameplay footage we will have it for you
later
we'd like to announce a new game today
well it's actually not completely a new
game but a game that's being reworked
from the ground up for consoles
meet eternal return lumia experiment
coming to a console near you later this
year
but we don't have any gameplay footage
to show you yet we sat down with tamura
koji the console pd at nimble neuron for
the development of this game for
consoles
enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to this very special interview
with the developers of eternal return
lumia experiment on console
please can you introduce yourself for a
[Music]
we of bite have a lot of questions today
um so i think our first question will be
on which platforms will eternal return
lumia experiment be available
playstation nintendome
um
all right and will all the characters in
eternal return be available in eternal
return lumia experiment
[Music]
is
[Music]
share the same universe lore and
characters as the pc version of eternal
return
and i think the question most players
will have right now when are we able to
play eternal return lumia experiment
why is it so important that eternal
return makes to the console platforms
will there be lots of differences
between eternal return and eternal
return lumia experiment what makes lumia
experiment unique from the other version
of
[Music]
foreign
foreign
what kind of xbox or playstation do i
need can i still play in the ps4 and
xbox one
so what changes in development have been
made in order to adapt lumia experiment
to the western audience
[Music]
[Music]
as an xbox player for example am i able
to play cross play with playstation and
pc players
games
[Music]
we have exclusive characters events and
gameplay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
eternal return on pc give me bonuses on
lumia experiment vice versa like skins
or emotes to encourage me to pick up
both
[Music]
bye
i hope you enjoyed this first episode of
cacao now
we couldn't be more excited to bring you
this new show and we will bring you more
episodes throughout the year to give you
updates on our titles and do
announcements
feel welcome to give us your feedback
while we try to improve this show for
future episodes
enjoy your day
see you in
[Music]
you